je trouve qu'elle a beaucoup de devoirs
et c'est vrai que je trouve que dans la
météo de ces émotions jeu la somme aux
orages composition il arrive c'est bien
là bas j'avais la montée là excusez moi
plus que manger de viande dans ces cas
là moi ensuite la viande infos plus
clairement
moi j'aimerais savoir qui c'était une
altercation entre enfants il a très peu
plu elle compterait plus me parler des
tice te plaît quand mon dieu donc nous
sommes ici pour parler de carnets carmen
quand même c'est le sens elle son frère
et le sang sera jamais de l'eau comme on
dit sur sybille raconte à toute la
classe que la terre est plate
qu'est ce qui vous dit que les ondes
bonjour monsieur bonjour ne vous est le
papa de rihanna
oui et non vous connaissez keane à la
map et oui ces petits quidams ap au même
âge
ryan c'est au dessus est-ce que ryan ça
a pesé de 200 millions je suis content
de vous rencontrer
j'avais déjà vu à plusieurs reprises la
maman d'angelina mais je connaissais pas
son papa co2 en jeu penche sur le fond
bozo non non non je vous en prie donc
vous êtes les parents d'inès alors oui
on a demandé à avoir une petite rente
entrevue avec vous parce que il s'avère
que moi et mon ex époux on a décidé de
se séparer en fait passer la 22e
téléphone alors donc il ya papa pascal
qui et pas parce que c'est moi c'est
vous et donc vous êtes papa jean
baptiste papa jubé tapas tibet s'est
enchanté du coup et inès vin peut être
baladés en fait gauche à droite ont tous
un beau mec t'es sérieux là
excusez moi monsieur oui vous êtes de la
famille gillett en pause et on travaille
là là moi je suis là il est toujours à
hilal machin il à le faire si ça
déraille au moins manger de la salade
nous on reconnaît un grain graines de
lin graines de chia grande courge
graines de psyllium puisqu'elle a besoin
de manger c'est une petite fille qui
tient pas la fin de la journée un mais
c'est vrai qu'en mathématiques bon mois
que vous pouvez éteindre le téléphone
portable
excusez moi et toi écoute maintenant
c'est toi tu mets coups de fils de [ __ ]
fois écoute moi bien toi tu crois que tu
va baiser qui toi ça vous dérange quand
je monte mon beurre à lézinnes la
cantine vous mettez des épinards des
betteraves c'est sympa mais il faut
mettre consiste à embêter du poulet du
calcium des vitamines
il faut que le petit il est cet apport
énergétique et journaliers qui lui
permettent de se dépasser physiquement
techniquement porter des masques à des
gamins mais j'ai pas le choix c'est les
règles monsieur s'est inventée par les
nazis avec se démerde
valérie est un petit garçon adorable
mais il ya des problèmes des bavardages
faut le taper sur ma chemise parce que
vraiment là je vais pas y un problème de
kribi si je peux enlever la chenille se
pendre of jah drache ans renault trucks
de caravanes ont tenu par mer ont rejeté
par la mort de johnny pour nous c'est
naturel
tu m'as dit johnny balavoine collège non
oui pas le truc sardou vivants n'ont
donc sage aventin on est là pour paris
d'enzo qui est un petit garçon fait
qu'il va bien vous saviez ce qu'ils
jouaient au foot on l'inscrit au
football ouais et besoins
pas que j'arrive mon pantalon
c'est incroyable quand même si ça
déplace comment voulez vous que les
gosses boss est un petit garçon heureux
il va bien on a du mal à comprendre où
vous voulez en venir
on sent un mal être un peu plus loin au
bout pointé du doigt c'est de nous donc
vous avez envie de parler parce que si
nous on peut vous raconter notre vie a
saoulé l'on peut voir ce qu'on va manger
ce soir peut voir demander si on va
avoir un rapport sexuel en quittant
cette salle mais peut-être même dans la
salle mais venant directement à nous de
l'amour chez pour ma fille il dépasse
l'entendement mais ça touche les
émotions voilà carmen à l'avance nous on
avance tout le monde est heureux moi on
a connu trop de misère asie on a
organisé l'anniversaire de sybille elle
était très contente et pas fait écouter
un petit peu de rab de musique urbaine
par hasard si c'est possible oui eh ben
on ne fait pas ça vous entendez le
niveau de bêtise des paroles c'est pas
le hasard des activités avec cheval est
là parce que je voulais me prendre et et
marque un record depuis il est
positionné ou dans la classe et au fond
à gauche
non il faudrait le mettre au fond à
droite parce que lui il est gaucher
comme ça s'ils rentrent au fond à droite
il se repositionne sur son bon pied et
ce qui lui permet de marquer demain je
serai là à 16h10 j'en attrapé un des
deux hazard parce que tu as entre ces
deux petits merdeux et je vais me les
ont tués devant les autres gamins oui
mais si ça ça ça triche encore au parce
que bon ça tricher avec le temps
aux gros tricheurs
le petit c'est un génie on a montré une
vidéo à messi messi la féuo mais s'il
fait jamais - on parlé de quelle gauche
ont servi de angelina assez pour la
tasse de prosper a non
[Musique]